[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débats il y avait sept
mois certaines routes secondaires
françaises notamment des yvelines
voyaient leur vitesse a baissé à 80
km/heure objectif faire diminuer le
nombre de morts sur les routes une
mesure impopulaire qui s'est invité dans
le grand débat national
le président emmanuel macron à ne s'est
pas montrée opposée à des aménagements
sur certains tronçons
le gouvernement est il en train de
reculer faut-il revenir aux 90 km heure
c'est le thème du débat de ce soir est
avec nous au plateau jean yves petit
bonsoir bonsoir à vous êtes le directeur
de l'association prévention routière
dans les yvelines
en face de vous luc lepeltier bonsoir
bonsoir z coordinateur de la fédération
des motards en colère également dans les
yvelines
merci à tous les deux d'avoir accepté
cette invitation
alors depuis le 1er juillet 2018 la
vitesse a donc été abaissé à 80 km/heure
sur un peu plus de 586 km de routes
yvelinoise 105 pannes ont été changés il
ya sept mois messieurs justement comment
avez vous accueilli cette mesure on
commence avec mon petit oui et bien là
l'association prévention routière
soutient la mesure avec toutefois la
réserve que nous aime nous aurions aimé
que
l'expérimentation soit poussé un peu
plus longuement puisque vous savez qu'il
ya eu pendant deux ans sur trois tons
sont trois tronçons qui totalisaient
environ 80 kilomètres dans le en france
la vitesse a baissé à 80 km/heure et
le gouvernement a décidé par la suite
d'étendre cette mesure comme on sait
aujourd'hui nous aurions aimé que
l'étude soit enfin l'expérimentation
soit un peu plus longue avant d'en tirer
des conclusions définitives
je pense que votre avis est un peu
différent oui c'est pas très surprenant
puisque dès le départ dell annonce de
cette mesure
ffmc s'est mobilisée dans le département
et au niveau national pour s'opposer à
cette mesure qui qui pour nous ne
présentait pas ne présentait pas un
intérêt majeur quand on parle
effectivement des tests qui ont été
réalisés faut savoir que ces tests ont
été très très partiel avec des routes
refaites et cetera en fait pour mais
tout en bonne condition
les résultats n'ont pas été communiqués
et donc on se retrouve depuis le 1er
juillet avec ce 80 kilomètres heure qui
a été de fait imposé par une personne
par le premier ministre sol qui a pris
la décision de faire ce 80 km heure donc
nous sommes opposés à ceux 80 km/heure
et nous demandons est que nous puissions
revenir à aux 90 90 que m
justement lors d'un déplacement en
janvier dans le cadre du grand débat
national emmanuel macron s'est montré
plutôt ouvert pour des aménagements sur
cette limitation de vitesse dans les
yvelines le président du conseil
départemental pierre bédier est lui
aussi favorable à un rétablissement de
la vitesse à 90 km/heure je vous propose
de l'écouter
l'argument d'épargner des vies est un
argument de mon point de vue fallacieux
parce que il suffit d'interdire la
voiture et on évitera les accidents de
voiture
et n'ayons des voitures qui circulent
casero km/heure et je vous garantis que
l'accidentologie sera ramené à rien du
tout donc il faut un peu de souplesse si
l'on autorise nous repasserons à 90
kilomètres à l'heure sur certains
tronçons
de notre point de vue passer à 80 km de
façon abusive
ce qui ne veut pas dire que sur d'autres
tronçons qui sont aujourd'hui à 80 il
faudrait pas passer à 70 soit 60
pourquoi pas même à 30 il faut que les
gens puissent se déplacer dans des
délais raisonnables
d'où la fluidité et avec la meilleure
sécurité possible en sachant que le
risque zéro dans cette activité comme
dans toute activité humaine n'existe pas
mais ce petit une réaction virile
tentatives n'ont alors vous m'aviez dit
je vous ai répondu à la question
précédente c'était notre position il ya
enfin l'année dernière au moment où ses
sorties aujourd'hui il est vrai que le
gouvernement facilite pas la tâche quand
même un avec ses valses hésitations les
je suis un peu de la vie de deux
présidents bédié pas forcément avec les
mêmes interne mais il a raison je pense
que nos élus locaux et nos décideurs
locaux devraient être à même de décider
eux mêmes dans la dans la limite de ce
qui est autorisé bien sûr là la
limitation de vitesse
on leur donne tout un tas de
responsabilité par ailleurs très
importante pourquoi pas cette
responsabilité là qu'ils ont déjà
d'ailleurs au moins dans les villes et
dans certains endroits
donc je pense qu'il faudrait largement
s'appuyer sur les décideurs locaux pour
adapter la limitation de vitesse alors
90 80 70 cents pour en reparler je
suppose un tout petit peu après mais je
vais à l'époque en fait l'argument
avancé par le gouvernement
c'était justement la baisse de la
mortalité sur les routes
justement si on regarde les chiffres
d'un peu plus près au niveau national le
nombre de tués sur les routes ban n'a
jamais été aussi bas en 2018 en 3259
tués dans les îles dans les yvelines
pardon on le voit à l'écran le nombre de
tués sur les routes a stagné en 2010 8
49 morts comment en 2010 est d'ailleurs
par contre le nombre d'accidents et de
blessés a baissé à lui que le pelletier
est ce que selon vous on peut faire le
lien entre l'abaissement cette vitesse à
80 km/heure et ce bilan plutôt positif
de la mortalité sur les routes notamment
non tout simplement non parce que
d'abord comme on l'a dit déjà les ce
sont des chiffres partiels sur quelques
mois donc je n'ai pas envie de commenter
plus plus longtemps
ces chiffres là juste dire que d'abord
la fnc se réjouit quand même que le
nombre de tués diminue ça c'est ça c'est
un fait
c'était en fait mais il faut savoir que
le nombre de tués baisse continue au
moins depuis 1972
c'est pas c'est pas nouveau c'est pas un
phénomène nouveau et donc est attribué
la baisse du nombre de tués 2 sur un an
sur sept sur sept dernières années les
attribuer à aux 80 km heure
je ne comprends même pas comment on peut
affirmer ce genre de chose puisque dans
ces tuer il n'y a pas que la vitesse il
ya d'autres critères pour nous pour nous
il y a eu il y a cinq cents sans tout
dévoiler mais il y a il ya l'alcool
ils y allaient drug il y à des
médicaments il yad'autres cosy et
l'infrastructure routière est ce que
vous vous rendez compte que vous pointez
d'ailleurs du doigt tout à fait les
infrastructures routières et
autoroutières king et qui dans les
yvelines et puis et puis ailleurs qui
présentent de plus en plus de problèmes
de dégradation qui de route ils sont
parfaites et des dangers potentiels à la
fois pour les automobilistes mais nous
aussi de roues plus spécifiquement ou un
nid-de-poule ou à un trou dans la route
est significatif de chute les voir des
accidents mortels voilà donc c'est tout
ça qu'il faut mettre en perspective et
port seulement ce 80 km/heure donc c'est
pour ça que je vous pour commenter plus
que ça des chiffres partiels un jean
yves petit sur les causes des accidents
justement dans les yvelines c'est vrai
qu'on met souvent en avant la vitesse
mais parce que c'est la première cause
des accidents qui permettait bonjour et
crème ajouter quelque chose sur ce que
sur ce qui vient d'être dit 3259 tuer
comme vous l'avez dit c'est le plus bas
historique
et contrairement à ce que vous avez dit
monsieur lepeltier vous savez qu'entre
2013 fin 2014 et 2018 savez savez
remonter donc c'était c'était quand même
assez assez inquiétant et la 2018 ça de
nouveau baissé de façon assez
spectaculaire puisqu'elle est maintenant
au plus bas historique mais ça avait
commencé à baisser à vrai dire dès le
mois de janvier 2018 et on n'a pas
attendu le mois de juillet 2018 pour
voir les chiffres des accidents baissé
et j'ajoute que donc l'état attribue aux
80 km/heure un ministre oui c'est ça un
gain de 116 tuer c'est du moins ce que
dit les communiqués de presse de la
sécurité routière sans cesse tu es si
c'est le cas tant mieux tant mieux bien
évidemment on peut que s'en réjouir
maintenant je n'ai pas plus de détails
que ça sur sur ces chiffres
je me suis penché un petit peu sur les
chiffres des yvelines et avec les
éléments dont je dispose c'est à dire
uniquement les cas d'accidents mortels
que vous devez avoir aussi probablement
et je me suis aperçu que dans le premier
semestre 2018
j'ai compté quatre tués sur les routes
concernées donc les routes communales et
départementales quatre tués au premier
semestre
quatre tués au deuxième semestre donc
c'est pas sur ces six mois en tout cas
c'est pas significatif et c'est pour ça
que nous pensons qu'il est
qu'il faut qu'il faut attendre encore
avant de tirer les conclusions
définitives
alors aujourd'hui la sécurité routière
justement a lancé une nouvelle campagne
qui diffusé dans les cinémas sur
internet on va voir quelques images
c'est une campagne qui met l'accent
justement sur le réseau secondaire des
routes donc ces fameuses routes qui ont
été abaissées pour la plupart à 80
km/heure et que l'on croit bien
connaître c'est ce que dit à la campagne
alors vous vous le disais juste avant en
fait ce n'est pas forcément sur ces
routes en fait où il ya selon vos
chiffres en fait où il ya le plus
d'accidents en tout cas dans l'est dans
les yvelines annonce certainement pas
sur ces routes là qu'il ya plus
d'accidents le plus sexy lancé en ville
dans les zones urbaines alors pas
forcément les accidents mortels mais
c'est bien là où il ya le plus
d'accidents avec toutes les causes que
vous avez indiquée par ailleurs l'alcool
la drogue la voirie enfin toutes les
causes qu'on connaît bien le téléphone
il ya énormément de cosmétiques aux oui
bien sûr bien sûr un autre et je suivrai
pas il ne faudrait pas imaginer qu'il ya
que la vitesse qui est qui qui tue mais
moi je voudrais avant de jurer revenir
sur la déclaration de monsieur bédié qui
est plein de bon sens qui est peu de mon
sens à mon sens parce que effectivement
il parle du 90 km heure il a parlé du 70
et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui avec ce 80 km heure on se
retrouve avec une panoplie de vitesse
sur des tronçons assez réduit ou le
l'usager qui soit automobilistes ou
motards ou même le camion etc se
retrouvent à devoir gérer un panel de
vitesse qui peut aller de 50 70 80 90
110 sur des tronçons assez réduit donc
ça devient ça devient n'importe quoi et
je pense que demain il faut
effectivement revenir à plein de bon
sens et travailler intelligemment pour
que on est une vitesse qui soit à la
fois comprise et partagée par l'ensemble
des usagers et ce n'est pas ce que le
gouvernement nous a montré ces derniers
temps et comme vous le rappeliez il
faudrait revenir un petit peu de bon
sens et surtout de demander aussi la vie
au visage et plus aux professionnels de
la route vous en tant que motard en tant
qu'automobiliste est-ce que vous avez
constaté que cette cette vitesse de 80
km a été respectée ce que vous l'avez
personnellement enfin est ce que vous
l'avez alors oui oui moi je vais enfin
je constate les ya beaucoup de gens qui
roulent effectivement je dirais même en
dessous de 80 et je dirais même aussi
que comme maintenant tout le monde est à
la même vitesse et à dire voitures motos
voitures camions autobus tous que tout
ce qui roule est à 80 km/heure on se
retrouve à faire parfois la chenille
derrière un camion derrière où se
retrouver dans des situations un peu un
peu un peu compliqué si vous l'avez
constaté vous que les gens respectent
finalement ou pas j'ai pas j'ai pas
chronométré non j'ai pas réellement
constatés çà personnellement mais le
le gouvernement en tout cas l'oni et
c'est enfin le les services du premier
ministre dans ce domaine là disent que
la vitesse moyenne a été abaissé de 4
4,5 km heure sur ces routes là sauf pour
les camions qui eux n'ont pas n'ont pas
changé donc il apparaît si on en croit
les chiffres officiels une baisse
effective de la vitesse sur ces routes
là ce débat touche bientôt à sa fin
une dernière question faut-il laisser
les routes secondaires à 80 km à 90
km/heure non non il faut il faut il faut
rapidement que le premier ministre
et puis emmanuel macron reviennent à
plein de bon sens
un kit à manger leur chapeau si l'on
loin mais il faut qu'ils reviennent aux
90 km heure parce que de toute façon
vous savez il ya une part faible de
délinquants de la route ainsi que de
toute façon 80 ou 90 nous respecterons
jamais la vitesse autorisée est maximale
autorisée donc ces gens là de toute
façon ils seront toujours en infraction
donc c'est ça sert à rien de vouloir
imposer à 80 km/heure à tout le monde
par rapport à 1 90 puisque s'il n'y a
pas de danger plus que ça de diminuer la
vitesse de 10 km heure sa vie un face à
face à 80 80 ou 90 90
de toute façon c'est le problème c'est
plus la vitesse c'est un problème de
comportement et je pense qu'il faut
mettre l'accent demain sur le
comportemental plutôt que sur la
répression
je suis un peu d'accord avec ce que vous
venez de dire et j'ajoute comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure que le 80 km
heure a ajouté un panneau
supplémentaires comme vous l'avait déjà
dit ça existe dans d'autres pays
européens il ya là c'est tout le 10 km
heure 1
chez nous c'est un peu moins
heureusement mais c'est ce que nos
concitoyens ont toujours critiqué sa
cette multiplicité des panneaux et donc
des infractions possibles
ce qui coûte cher sans qu'on de bonne
foi on n'a pas fait attention
donc quand on aura la voiture autonome
et que ça sera directement réglés grâce
au gps / pour tout le monde là il y aura
plus de soucis aujourd'hui avoir comme
vous l'avez dit 50 70 80 90 110 ça fait
beaucoup de panneaux alors peut-être
faudrait-il mieux supprimer le 80 et
faire 70 et 90 comme c'était le cas
auparavant d'ailleurs j'avoue que je
n'ai pas de conviction trancher là
dessus mais le débat n'est pas simple et
le gouvernement lancé ce débat
ils s'en sortent et justes aux galates
oseo dont l'un des panneaux oui celle
ayant fait ravi c'est bien mais c'est le
fait on détourne l'attention de l'usager
qui doit être concentré sur la route on
le détourne pour regarder des panneaux
merci à tous les donateurs étaient
présents voilà c'est la fin de cette
fille débat mercredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro
[Musique]